8 million metric tons of plastic trash
enters the sea from land every year the
equivalent of five plastic bags filled
with trash for every foot of coastline
in the world across our ocean plastic
trash flows into circulation dispersed
almost everywhere but concentrating in
huge swathes in the midst of global
currents breaking down into smaller and
smaller pieces ingested by species
across the marine world and sinking to
the bottom of the sea
anyone can make plastic anywhere in the
world and sell it anywhere else in the
world there's no design paradigm there's
no barriers in order to solve the
plastic packaging problem we need to
effectively rethink the entire system
from one which is linear ie take make
dispose to one where it can be recovered
and fed back into the economy as a
valuable plastic material all one where
it is by over nine and it can enter the
environment the ultimate goal of the new
plastics economy is to design an economy
where plastic packaging never becomes
waste and to do that we need every
single player in the chain to change the
way that they do things but marine
pollution comes in many forms
industrial agricultural and urban waste
also sweep into the sea fueling
explosions of algae that robbed marine
ecosystems of the oxygen they need to
survive with sustained pollution these
areas become dead zones which already
exist in more than 400 locations across
the globe but nutrient pollution can be
managed through change in major
contributing systems like agriculture if
you eat you're involved in agriculture
so it's a problem that all of us have to
work together to solve soil health is
critical for water quality it's the
first thing we have to focus on here on
the farm
organic matter is the key thing that we
try to improve the more organic matter
you have in the soil the better the soil
can hold on to nutrients like phosphorus
and nitrogen organic matter keeps it
from leaching out of the soil it grabs
on to it and that's good for the farmer
but it's also good for water quality in
the bay for any farmer to change their
system is tricky and it takes a lot of
work I think all farmers want to it's
learning different processes practices
that allow you to do it effectively that
becomes a key
[Music]